I do have family members with Down
Syndrome it almost got me
up I dodged it but it nicked me it
nicked me it's funny when you bring up
down syndrome you can always tell who's
never been around it in their lives like
if I tell people if I'm like yeah I have
family members with Down Syndrome people
that have never been around it are
always oh like down syndrome is the
end of the world oh they're
doing better than everybody I know
they're the only dudes I know having a
good time pretty consistently sorry
they're not on adderal and
anti-anxiety like the rest of us they're
on Capri Suns my uncle Danny
sneaks grilled cheese sandwiches into
restaurants just in case they don't
serve grilled cheese
sandwiches you look across the table you
see them sneaking at grilled
cheese yo where'd you get that chei
Danny his dad's with him he's like that
he's been making him at night I
know he is I'm not making him at night
dad then he'll look at you and be like
I'm making him at night